denn meine damen und herren ein halbes
jahr corona liegt hinter uns und ich
will als erstes mich ausdrücklich den
dank und der hochachtung denen die
bundeskanzlerin hier ausgesprochen hat
an die bürgerinnen und bürger
anschließen
deutschland steht was die pandemie
betrifft relativ gut da und das ist
zuallererst ein verdienst der
bürgerinnen und bürger deswegen ist ihr
appell auch richtig und ich schließe
mich auch diese man allerdings will ich
zwei dinge anmerken das erste ist wir
werden mit grosser mit großer
zurückhaltung weiteren grundrechts
einschränkungen entgegenstehen weil das
ist ein problem und rechts einstellung
genauso wie die macht des parlaments ist
problematisch und zweitens die panne wie
bekämpfung wird immer mehr zu einer
bühne für das vortanzen der merkel herrn
was die ministerpräsidenten aus
nordrhein westfalen und aus bayern nutzt
oder schadet das darf aber überhaupt
kein kriterium sein und danach sogar
menschen beschimpft als faulenzer nur
weil er nach aufmerksamkeit schreibt
dann ist das nicht in ordnung ihre
hausinterne probleme beeinflussende
zwischen die entscheidung und damit
verspielen sie vertrauen bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und schaden dem
land will nur als ein beispiel hier
anführen
der fototermin auf schloss
herrenchiemsee
es war eine inszenierung für markus
söder dem ministerpräsidenten mit der
miesesten corona bilanz vor merkel
ich wundere mich dass sie sowas
mitmachen wundert mich
liebe kollegen pflegen
daher lehnen daher etwas zu der
tarifauseinandersetzung gesagt hat
nebenbei im öffentlichen dienst will ich
da auch etwas zu sagen dass die politik
das die öffentlichen arbeitgeber nach
diesen monat nach den letzten monaten
nicht in der lage sind die streiks im
öffentlichen dienst abzuwenden ist eine
zumutung für die bürgerinnen und bürger
die forderungen von verdi sind
berechtigt wir geben milliarden in die
wirtschaft jetzt müssen die menschen
dran sein die das land am laufen halten
das sei das mindeste ist eine frage von
respekt meine damen und herren jetzt zum
haushalt der haushalt ist der letzte
dieser bundesregierung die haben darauf
hingewiesen er soll zentrale
weichenstellung vornehmen
mir scheint allerdings dass manches nur
deshalb entschieden wird weil sie frau
bundeskanzlerin aufhören und weil olaf
scholz kanzlerkandidat werden will oder
kanzler werden würde nicht nur ihrer
politik ist mit diesem haushalt sichtbar
ausschließlich der wahltermin
dieser haushalt ist ein wahlkampf
haushalt das ist das riesenproblem
wir nehmen so viel schulden auf die noch
in die 314 milliarden
und es ist auch völlig richtig nicht
gegen die krise anzusparen
vieles von dem war notwendig um
arbeitsplätze um betriebe zu werden
aber sie sagen überhaupt nicht werden
die 314 milliarden bezahlen wollte
wer zahlt denn die rechnung sie geben
keine antwort und keine antwort ist
ihnen auch eine antwort sie sagen sogar
sie wollen 20 22 zurück zur
schuldenbremse von 96,2 milliarden auf
zirka zehn milliarden in mainz lockt ihn
doch kein mensch das ist doch absurd
dass es völlig absurd sie machen schon
jetzt ein spardruck auf den sozialstaat
damit auf es wird ein kürzungs hammer
drohen das ist die realität meine damen
ich will mal daran erinnern wie das nach
der bankenkrise war wie sie das damals
gemacht haben
nach der bankenkrise gab es in
deutschland 500.000 vermögensmillionäre
mehr und die bürgerinnen und bürger
durften die schulden die die banken
gerettet haben mit dem verfall der
infrastruktur bezahlen das ist die
wahrheit meine damen und herren
und nicht einmal jetzt in der
allergrößten krise in der korona krise
trauen sie sich die superreichen in
unserem land mal an den kosten zu
beteiligen was ist dann so absurd eine
einmalige vermögensabgabe wie sie im
grundgesetz vorgesehen ist wirklich
umzusetzen das ist inakzeptabel
schauen sie sich doch mal die neuesten
vermögen zahlen an das obere zehn
prozent besitzt zwei drittel des
vermögens warum trauen sie sich nicht
mal da etwas abzuholen meine damen und
herren
und er wirklich der wirklich große rolle
der wäre natürlich eine große
steuerreform lieber herr finanzminister
eine große steuerreform die kleine und
mittlere einkommen wirklich entlastet
die kleine mittlere betriebe den
mittelstand entlasten und die vor die
krisenkosten schützt und entlastet wir
müssen wieder dahin kommen dass wirklich
leistung in unserem land eine rolle
spielt und nicht erbschaft bus ist es
nur erste auch die die viel haben wir
können weitermachen
da ist die hinter stimmt was lieber herr
scholz nicht handeln wird manchmal
teurer als zu handeln
deswegen muss auf diesem feld endlich
gehalten abgehandelt werden über ihren
haushalt da freut sich insbesondere der
geldadel und die rüstungsindustrie das
ist die wahrheit und ein wort zu den
kommunen ja es ist richtig bei den kurs
kosten der unterkunft diese
75-prozentige entlastung durchzuführen
aber ehrlich gesagt das wird in keiner
weise reichen die kommunen werden die
leidtragenden sein
da wird jetzt schon an allen ecken und
enden gespart und wird es wird natürlich
zu alt vor allem zu lasten der
investitionen gehen auch der
ökologischen investitionen
sie verlagern die verantwortung und das
ist indiskutabel
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir erleben die schwerste
wirtschaftskrise seit jahrzehnten
das allen klar bis hoffen sie
offensichtlich ein altmaier mein problem
ist ja nicht mal dass sie die lage
beschönigen mein problem ist dass sie
real viel zu wenig für die
wirtschaftliche erholung tun ihr
konjunkturpaket ist das prinzip
gießkanne unglaublich teuer ineffektiv
und ungerecht man als
wirtschaftsminister muss ihnen doch
auffallen dass aktuell ganz viele
unternehmen ihre betriebsstätten ins
ausland verlegen worden und da muss doch
klar sein dass wir alle darum kämpfen
dass keine betriebsstätten verlagert
werden vor allen dingen darf aber kein
geld geben wenn es betriebsverlagerung
gibt wenzel das gesehen hat dann muss
das zurückgefordert werden meine damen
und herren und besonders katastrophal
ist dass der steuerzahler die dividenden
von konzern mitfinanzieren warum zahlen
sie staatshilfen wenn dividenden
ausgeschüttet werden und die übernahme
von sozialversicherungsbeiträgen der
kurzarbeiter der wissel startet das ist
dreiste umverteilung von der
allgemeinheit zu den aktionären die
klattens und quandt sind ein besonderes
beispiel die beiden haben in diesem jahr
700 millionen euro für nichts zu tun
also nur auf ihr aktienpaket bekommen
und sie subventionieren dass mit
steuergeld warum zahlen nicht quandt und
lappen als eigentümer das
kurzarbeitergeld das wäre doch mal eine
sinnvolle maßnahme das bmwi und andere
staatshilfen und gleichzeitig
das ist schwer daneben und nichts
anderes
wie sagt der ig metall chef hoffmann
dazu besonders glänzend läuft das
geschäft mit luxuskarossen wie der s
klasse auch diese krise ist keine krise
der einkommen starken in diesem land
keine einzige einkommen stark in diesem
land das ist die wahrheit die
veranstaltungsbranche hat letzte woche
hier demonstriert was sagen sie
eigentlich denen die gefahr einer
riesigen insolvenz und pleitewelle die
ist real wie helfen sie denn den kleinen
unternehmen den freiberuflern den solo
selbstständigen den künstlerinnen und
künstler die verweisen sie im prinzip
auf hartz iv mehr tun sie nicht werden
sie bei den großen konzernen mit
milliarden agieren das ist eine schwere
schieflage stärke gibt stärke der
deutschen wirtschaft sind aber nicht die
großen konzerne sondern es sind die hart
arbeitenden arbeitnehmer
es sind die vielen kleineren und
mittleren betriebe der mittelstand das
ist die wahrheit und der altmaier die
muss es noch geben wenn der aufschwung
kommt und wenn sie dass sie aktuell hand
gucken die stellenstreichung ob bei
continental made schaeffler und und und
dann haben wir ein riesiges problem und
wir zumindest einmal frau
bundeskanzlerin an die werften und legt
in mecklenburg vorpommern erinnern hier
haben sie auch eine ganz persönliche
verpflichtung das dicke ende
meine damen und herren der
wirtschaftskrise steht uns noch bevor
und ein grund ist wirklich die
wirtschafts politik dieser
bundesregierung
die arbeitslosigkeit steigt nicht alle
kern aus der kurzarbeit in ihren job
zurück und vor allen dingen sind die
reallöhne laut statistischem bundesamt
im zweiten quartal so stark gefallen wie
noch nie und besonders stark ist der
rückgang in den unteren
einkommensgruppen
wir brauchen nicht nur einen
rettungsschirm für die wirtschaft
sondern einen sozialen schutzschirm für
die menschen in diesem land das ist das
gebot
verdammt soziale sicherheit beginnt
damit dass eigentlich selbstverständlich
auch zu tun nämlich dass man von seiner
arbeit auch leben kann und sie erhöhen
sage und schreibe den mindestlohn zum
ersten januar um 15 cent das ist eine
verhöhnung von millionen
leistungsträgern in dieser gesetzt
fragen sie wirklich sind 15 cent ihr
dank für die krone zeit ist dass es das
schon ihren applaus geblieben
zigtausende verkäuferin pflegerin
paketboten genau die die vor monaten
noch systemrelevant waren die müssen
sogar aufstocken
das heißt im klartext die werden so
schlecht bezahlt dass sie trotz vollzeit
noch zum sozialamt müssen in deutschland
verdient zehn millionen
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
weniger als zwölf euro
der niedriglohnsektor ist aber nicht
billig sondern der ist teuer und zwar
für die steuerzahler und für den
haushalt wir könnten zehn milliarden 10
milliarden im jahr sparen und sinnvoll
einsetzen bei einem entsprechenden
mindestlohn
wir fordern sie deshalb auch erhöhen sie
noch in dieser legislaturperiode den
mindest nur noch auf 12 euro ich hab das
doch x-mal selbst aus der regierung
gehört aber passieren tut real viel zu
wenig und die folge ist die folge von
mini lohn sind dann die mini renten von
morgen für die folgen schlechter löhne
geben wir noch mal sieben milliarden
dann für grundsicherung im alter aus
deshalb kleine haushalte
beenden sie ausbeutung und lohndumping
in deutschland das senkt die
staatsausgaben und damit die
soziale sicherheit und solide
staatsfinanzen sind eben keine
gegensätze im gegenteil sie fordern zu
recht von den bürgern eine maske zu
tragen wir fordern von ihnen nur legen
sie ihre ideologischen scheuklappen ab
meine damen und herren kinder und
familien insbesondere alleinerziehende
waren und sind teils noch immer
verlierer dieser krise daher ich teile
das es darf nicht zu einem ähnlichen
lockdown und flächendeckenden kita und
schulschließungen kommen das muss
regional entschieden werden das ist
richtig aber ich will auch darauf
hinweisen dass in der pandemie die
kinderarmut in unserem land weiter
gestiegen hat und damit können wir uns
allesamt nicht abfinden jedes kind muss
gleiche tanz und ich will in diesem
zusammenhang aus ihrem koalitionsvertrag
zitieren da steht drin wir werden
kinderrechte im grundgesetz ausdrücklich
verankert kinder sind grundrechtsträger
ihre rechte haben für uns
verfassungsrang
das haben sie in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
aufgeschrieben und sie machen gar nichts
in die richtung es kommt nicht ins
grundgesetz
union und spd haben wir offensichtlich
die bevölkerung selbst mit dem
koalitionsvertrag verklagt versprochen
und gebrochen
das ist die realität und das ist
notwendig war das haben wir in
besonderer weise in der korona krise
gesehen warum ist kanzler sie haben
sofort einen autogipfel nach wenigen
tagen ausgerichtet aber ein schulgipfel
der ist erst monate später angesetzt
worden
das sagt alles über die
prioritätensetzung dieser
bundesregierung meine damen und herren
und dann sagen sie ja ja die länder sind
ständig gefahren überhaupt wieso wenn
der bundesbildungsministerin auf der
bundesebene haben das ist also wirklich
eine zulässige frage und jetzt jetzt
habe ich heute auch von ihm gehört es
soll laptops eben wegen der
digitalisierung deshalb olaf scholz
gestern auch gesagt
ehrlich gesagt donnerwetter kann ich da
nur sagen es ist doch schon 2016 2016
von der kultusministerkonferenz
beschlossen worden was ist denn da bis
heute passieren wissen sie
was wir im bildungssystem vor allen
dingen brauchen liebe frau merkel gut
bezahlte lehrerinnen und lehrer wir
haben aktuell einen dramatischen
lehrermangel das ist unser hauptproblem
lehrerinnen und lehrer kleinere klassen
das ist entscheidend wenn alle kinder
mitkommen wollen meine damen und herren
ich mache ihnen damals wird den
konkreten vorschlag kippen sie dass zwei
prozent ziel der nato gibt sich als 2
prozent zu die der nato wir haben einen
bildungsnotstand aber kein land groß die
bundesrepublik meine damen und herren
wenn wir jährlich zehn milliarden
einsparen dann könnten wir das ziel
erreichen dass es keine klasse in
deutschland mit mehr als 15 schülerinnen
und schülern gebe dass wir mal eine
wirkungsvolle maßnahme und wir würden
kein geld verbrennen kein steuergeld für
trump und das nato ziele sondern wir
würden damit eines der besten und
gerechtesten schulsysteme der welt
aufbauen
das wäre eine maßnahme sozialpolitisch
bildungspolitisch und übrigens auch
integrationspolitisch schlechte schulen
und kinderarmut sind eine toxische
mischung die wir endlich auflösen müssen
ein reiches land mit der stärksten
wirtschaft europas darf doch keine
schlechten schulen haben doch was
passiert war
sie geben milliarden für die rüstung aus
der verteidigungsetat ist bei dieser
regierung um 21 prozent gestiegen warum
erhöhen sie mitten in der krise jetzt
auch noch die rüstungsausgaben deutlich
warum geben sie mehr geld für rüstung
aus als für gesundheit und bildung
zusammen das ist inakzeptabel
wir haben meine damen und herren jede
jede zweite rente liegt in deutschland
unter 1000 euro
davon haben 2,4 millionen rentnerinnen
und rentner über 40 jahre eingezahlt und
ihre grundrente ändert daran nichts
in den niederlanden da gibt es wirklich
eine grundrente die ihren namen verdient
keine rentnerinnen und kein rentner
klickt dort unter tausende 255 euro und
das ist bei uns ganz anders
deutschland hat die stärkste wirtschaft
aber bei schulen und bei renten sind wir
abstiegskandidaten in europa wenn ein
durchschnittsverdiener in wien und ein
durchschnittsverdiener in würzburg in
rente gehen dann gibt es in wien 800
euro mehr rente mehr heißen wird wie
wollen sie das wirklich erklären
deshalb nutzen sie diese nutzen die
krise für eine grundlegende reform
und wir machen einen vorschlag lassen
wir mal zunächst alle abgeordneten des
nächsten bundestages in die gesetzliche
rente einzahlen das wäre doch mal ein
wichtiges symbol wir brauchen eine
rentenkasse in die alle einzahlen
wir werden hier noch vor weihnachten
einen entsprechenden antrag vorlegen und
den sollten sie dann zustimmen das wäre
zumindest endlich wieder eine zweite
großbaustelle des sozialstaates ist die
pflege pflege wird immer mehr zur
armutsfalle
es kann doch nicht sein dass ein
pflegeplatz in deutschland 2.000 euro
oder teilweise noch deutlich mehr koste
das ist kein eigenanteil mehr
das ist enteignung meine damen und
und was tun sie dagegen was tun sie
dagegen
jeder dritte pflegeheimbewohner muss
inzwischen sozialhilfe beantragen
wozu gibt es denn eigentlich eine
pflegeversicherung fragen da viele
betroffene weil sie haben hoffentlich
nach der pandemie im gesundheitswesen zu
gelernt dass kommerzialisierung wirklich
der falsche weg ist und dass wir in
dieser frage auch wirklich die
eigentumsfrage stellen müssen aber wo
ist denn aktuell die bessere bezahlung
in der kranken und altenpflege
wann senken sie denn mal die
eigenanteile die pflegeversicherung hat
zehn milliarden mehr in diesem jahr als
2007 und trotzdem fließt weniger geld in
die altenheime ihr sparprogramm müssen
die bewohner durch explodierende kosten
und das pflegepersonal über mangel ohne
bezahlen
ein sozialstaat ohne ein gutes renten
und pflegesystem ist wie eine schule
ohne lehrer meine damen und herren hier
müssen sie handeln
hier auch nicht hinter der pandemie
verstecken meine damen und herren
handlungsbedarf ist angesagt für die
menschen die dort arbeiten wie sie in
den letzten wochen und monaten vielfach
beklagt haben sie sie geben hunderte
milliarden aus und schaffen aber nicht
dieses land mit diesem haushalt erst
recht nicht krisenfest zu machen
mit einem teil des geldes nur mit einem
teil des geldes könnten wir den
sozialstaat das gesundheitssystem und
die schulen fit machen für die nächsten
jahre
stattdessen wird durch ihre politik
durch ihre art steuergeld ausgegeben
dass das land nach der krise noch tiefer
gespalten sein wird und dass meine damen
und herren ist ein riesenproblem deshalb
diese haushalt der kann nicht krise
dieser haushalt kann überhaupt nicht
soziale sicherheit dieser haushalt kann
nicht zukunft und deswegen sollte er
grundsätzlich verändert werden
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]